[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast with me
and my brother John give you a dubious
advise answer your questions and bring
you all the week's news for both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon occasionally
apparently it's been so long since we've
been together I miss you John how you do
I'm doing well I feel like since we last
recorded a podcast Hank the the world
has turned into a proper dumpster fire
and between the time that we record this
podcast and when it is made available
for listening I bet something else
terrible has happened so I would just
like to say in advance I am sorry that
the world has turned into such a
horrible dumpster fire yeah I have no
faith that this the the the days that
are separated the recording and the
uploading of this podcast will not
contain something that will make
something inside of this podcast seem
insensitive and wrong which is not a
feeling I want to have so let's I yeah I
it's bad year it's about here John you
know Hank I think it's been a bit of a
dumpster fire the whole time do you
remember back in like March or April of
this year when I was like it's not an
unusually bad year people are just
paying unusual amounts of attention to
the badness mmm I would like to
officially retract that statement it is
that bad of a year earth is a dumpster
fire we need to run away from it as fast
as possible and colonize Mars starting
in the year 2028 sounds sounds great
John I I'm glad that we're on the same
the same team almost well we're on the
same team it's just that we're on
slightly different schedules right well
we'll talk more about that in the end
the final segment of the podcast I I in
my personal life though John I should
say that things are going just just fine
I feel pretty good I feel good about our
projects I feel good about nerdfighteria
I feel good about the dear Hank and John
podcast so the world can stop throwing
garbage into the garbage fire that'd be
great
if we could just let it burn itself out
but our our little part pocket of it I
think is is good and I'll be thing
go for it if I can I've just got to say
Hank that hearing you say that makes it
sound like you're just warming your
hands next to the dumpster fire enjoying
the heat I'm not I'm not at all
Oh would you like a short poem for today
yes
this isn't that short of a poem but I
think it's it's the right one to read
this week it's by Adam's Agra uski it's
called try to praise the mutilated world
try to praise the mutilated world
remember June's long days and wild
strawberries drops of rose a wine the
nettles that methodically overgrow the
abandoned homesteads of exiles you must
praise the mutilated world you watched
the stylish yachts and ships one of them
had a long trip ahead of it while salty
oblivion awaited others you've seen the
refugees going nowhere
you've heard the executioner's sing
joyfully you should praise the mutilated
world
remember the moments when we were
together in a white room and the curtain
fluttered return and thought to the
concert where music flared you gathered
acorns in the park in autumn and leaves
eddie'd over the Earth's scars praised
the mutilated world and the gray feather
a thrush lost and the gentle light that
strays and vanishes and returns try to
praise the mutilated world by Adams
Aggie you ski
thanks for bringing thanks for bringing
us up John I like to bring it all the
way up to the energy started out on a
pretty rough note but you really brought
it back I like that's what I like to do
man I like to take it from down to down
even lower oh I was a beautiful poem I I
want to answer some questions though I
want to move it before we get to the
question st. can we just go through a
few Corrections oh sure sure we have a
we we've been off away for a long time
so we have so many things to say it
turns out that when you take two weeks
off you make even more mistakes than
usual okay so first off a bunch of
people from Gillingham wrote in to say
that I am mispronouncing Gillingham but
I would argue that it's like Jif or gif
both pronunciations are correct I do not
know for sure how to say Gillingham and
or Gillian ham but I will die in the
belief
that both are acceptable pronunciations
secondly Hank I believe in our last
podcast you said that there is no City
built around a shoe that is in fact
incorrect yes that there was no downtown
area constructed around a very large
shoe was was the thing that I said could
not possibly be and yet it is it is
Meghan wrote in to say in Freeport Maine
there is a giant LL Bean complex
centered around a giant boot downtown
Freeport is basically constructed around
a very large shoe so there you go Hank
also many people wrote in to say that
there are efficient ways to keep your
headphone cord from tangling I only
mention this because one of the ways
involved a Dutch word which is voulons
ACOG and deutscher beam durga which i
will remind you that mispronouncing
things is my thing and that is the dutch
word hank for the little ties that you
use to tie up your trash bags like a
twist tie well i guess you could call it
a twist tie but why call it a twist tie
when you could call it a vuln is scott
candidate you're beaten dirt chuck good
call john i agree with you completely
alexander additionally wrote in to
correct me last episode he says you guys
asked how much less a car would weigh if
its tires were filled with helium
unfortunately it wouldn't make it any
lighter helium balloons float because
they're less dense than the surrounding
atmosphere but when you fill your car
tires you have to pressurize them so you
actually can drive as you pressurize
helium or any gas for that matter its
density increases by the time you've
pressurized your tyres enough to drive
the helium would be denser than the
surrounding atmosphere and wouldn't
float even without the weight of the car
or the tires ah that's a bummer dang it
lastly several people wrote in to say
that the night feeling I described this
feeling of longing or homesickness for
for some place you don't quite know or
for something you don't quite understand
a feeling that Hank says he's never had
because Hank well you know you look into
his cold dead eyes and you see nothing
but the lack of a soul it turns out
there are a couple words for that Hank
just not in English there is a Welsh
word hi Wraith her 8th and a German word
Sehnsucht Sehnsucht
there's a German word for everything of
course and so there are words for it
just not in English so I am NOT alone in
having that feeling though Hank many
people wrote in to say that you are a
monster and that I am the only human
between us well once upon a time you
believed that you were the only human on
earth so you're making progress oh man
excuse me I have to apply a bit of
pointment to that burn all right dad
here is our first question are you ready
for our first question I am
it's from William who asks dear Hank and
John my wife and I Foster and trained
dogs that our local rescue pulls from
high kill shelters in central California
we get a huge diversity of dogs in
different shapes and sizes and breeds
but most of them have one thing in
common they love to drink from the
toilet none of my other dogs the non
shelter dogs have ever liked to drink
that fresh cold potty water but despite
the never-ending stream of cold fresh
sink water the dogs prefer the cold
fresh potty water here's where I could
use some dubious advice should I bottle
and sell this cold fresh potty water is
there a larger human market for cold
fresh potty water just waiting to be
tapped
a good pun there what dear Hank and John
have room for some sponsorship from cold
fresh potty water any advice would be
greatly appreciated William cook CEO of
cold fresh potty water first off I just
want to say as far as sponsorship goes I
will take any amount of money from
anyone to sponsor this podcast I just
want a real sponsor I don't even do who
it is I don't even care if it's Diet Dr
Pepper at this man we could get a
sponsor if we wanted one I think there's
all kinds of podcast networks out there
we're on that we're on the lists John I
mean all right we do it man I don't do
tea water send disease you uh what's the
going rate for a podcast sponsorship
eight dollars ten well maybe just maybe
just in product maybe just send us a
bunch of cold fresh body water you know
what William we don't really need your
money what we need is your cold fresh
potty water I mean your dogs think it's
good it must be no it's not good you
shouldn't sell it and you shouldn't
allow your dogs to drink that cold fresh
potty water that's because one thing
that you probably don't know William is
that every day whether you like it or
not
you are eating your dog's poop so you
are basically eating the pooped out like
remnants of your cold fresh potty water
you just need to lock the doors to all
the bathrooms at all times that is the
solution I will say that that no matter
what anybody tells you you shouldn't
drink water out of the toilet if you're
a human if you're a dog I don't know it
seems like it seems like it works for
them there they have different
constitutions than us but yeah in
general it's a surprise but truth that
if you're letting your dog lick your
face you got a bunch of dog poop in your
mouth it's a true fact it's okay uh-huh
oh god I don't even I don't even want to
think about it anymore
do you know I once had a Campylobacter
infection Hank an infection caused
exclusively or at least almost
exclusively by even the poop of your pet
well it does happen ah let's move on to
another question Hank this one comes
from Aaron who writes Dear John and Hank
growing up dyslexic it was always a
painful mystery to me why words refuse
to be spelled in a manner that would
allow me to know how to build them I
realize this is due in part to the way
our language was developed but I really
don't care
in every entry in the dictionary there
is a phonetic spelling that follows
rules why not just use those sorry no
death Oh Ryan Aaron it is disappointing
to me that you aren't named Ryan Aaron
but I'm gonna answer your question
anyway there's a great Mark Twain essay
called spelling reform a plan for the
improvement of English spelling and if
you read it over the course of the essay
it gets less and less legible at least
to me as the spelling becomes more and
more phonetic there are a couple reasons
we don't do phonetic spelling one is
that it's actually less comprehensible
than you might think to see those words
spelled like they're spelled in the
dictionary all next to each other the
biggest reason we don't do it this has
actually been attempted before Hank with
some money from Andrew Carnegie and
there was support from Teddy Roosevelt
in the early 20th century to like reform
English spelling mostly to get the
silent vowels out of English the biggest
reason we don't do it is because of the
mass of people who are at
know how to read in current English and
who don't want to make accommodations
for people for whom reading in English
is difficult that's basically what it
boils down to yeah there are a number of
examples of things that that would that
we could do eat more easily but but we
have this this cultural knowledge that
continues to span throughout and like it
is just so difficult to change because
by the time it's time to change you you
would have to change all the people who
currently exist and even if it would
benefit greatly all the people who will
exist in the future the people who
currently exist kind of are the ones who
have the most say at the moment because
they currently exist so they just
continue to screw over all the people
from the future and that is true and it
is also why your keyboard is laid out in
the way that is not the most efficient
way for a keyboard to be laid out and
yet it will never ever change
it's also why you calculate you know in
miles instead of in kilometers yes and
also why our our minutes are 60 in an
hour instead of a hundred because what
what whoa I quite like having 60 minute
hours because then you can have a 60
second minute and you can have 24 hours
in a day it all it's all dried up tons
of cents just that way also you can have
365 days in one year well this feels
convenient that John is actually defined
by the solar system so we can't no no no
no no no no no no no no we could fix
that we could do something about that we
could address that problem to speed the
speed it up well yeah I just I we need
to either have 100 year 100 day years or
1000 day years one or the other the
earth can pick the proper rotational
speed to make that happen there I mean
Hank we can put a man on Mars but we
can't like shoot rockets from one corner
of Earth in order to make it spin slower
so that I can have a hundred day year
first of all I can't okay I haven't yet
figured out how to put a man on Mars
second I did read a book one time in
which they sped up the rotation of a
planet by slamming comets into it which
is pretty cool yeah that would work yeah
totally let's do that that's what I'm
proposing I would like a slightly fast
year let's have some comets at us I bet
that's what's gonna happen Hank that's
what's gonna be the horrible news story
between now and Monday and I'm gonna
seem so terrible for having made that
joke yep yep well half we won't even be
able to up with a podcast John this
question is people will be like it was
so insensitive
that he made that joke about the actual
end of human life on this planet which
did actually end Monday afternoon all
right John here's a slightly more
serious question I believe from Sarah
who asks dear Hank and John I'm
currently in graduate school getting a
PhD and trying to tell people about it
is my problem usually when people ask me
what I'm studying I tell them
neuroscience and then they have this
visceral reaction like oh my god you
must be so smart I could never do that
they seem to feel like they can't talk
to me about what I'm studying which is
sad for me any dubious advice on how to
make my field of study sound more
approachable and not so daunting I mean
I'm pretty intimidated by the study of
neuroscience I have to say but once you
get up to a certain level every field of
study is intimidating right like I can
talk about political science to you but
I can't really talk about political
science to a political scientist because
they're just tuned all right well yeah I
I have found because I have a weird job
that that people will often if I tell
them what I'd like I'm a youtuber then
it's just they're just made of questions
to be a little more specific and so
instead of saying like I'm studying
neuroscience you can talk exactly tell
them exactly what you're studying at the
moment like I'm studying how chemicals
in the brain affect our sleep cycles or
whatever you're doing doing research on
or studying at the moment and that is
suddenly like oh that's not that doesn't
seem like brain surgery it seems like oh
interesting tell me more about the
chemicals in my brain that affect how
and when I sleep and in the same way I
usually instead of saying I'm a youtuber
I say I make educational videos for
students and teachers and then they're
like oh I understand what that is I
understand that the value equation there
and and also
I don't have to talk for for an hour
straight about how the economics of
online video wait is that really what
you say you make you say I make
educational video for students and
teachers correct yes do you know what I
say when I when I when I'm asked what I
do what do you say I say I work for an
educational video company oh wow
because you know what everyone says
after that what oh and that's the end of
the conversation it's great sometimes
it's nice to talk about what you do a
little bit you know have a conversation
oh man I dislike talking about what I do
so much it makes me so uncomfortable
like you can see my physical body like
close up like like a flower at nighttime
I don't want to I don't want to cast
blame but it's possible that you just
don't like talking to people
hmm it's true that it's not my favorite
thing to do it's not my like number one
huh my number one hobby is definitely
being by myself making up stories well
all right Hank we've got another
question this one comes from Sam who
writes dear john and hank i work in the
theme park Nickelodeon universe which is
located inside the Mall of America so so
Sam has just described my actual hell in
order to evoke a youthful ambience in
the park our IT department plays a
variety of pop songs extremely loudly
through the speaker system it's getting
worse
there are 15 songs that play on repeat I
I don't know if I can go on and these
songs are changed about once every three
months three you have any dubious advice
on how not to lose one's mind when
forced to hear the same 15 songs nine
hours a day forty hours a week I
estimate that I have heard boom clap
from The Fault in Our Stars soundtrack
about four thousand times in the past
three months which seems a bit excessive
oh wow I mean this needs to be like that
song gated this needs to be investigated
by like out like a the an agency of the
government in charge of the the health
and safety of workers yeah doesn't OSHA
have some regulations about the number
of times boom clap can be played in one
40-hour week work week I my wife
actually had a similar experience she
worked in a
a souvenir shop for a summer and and
listened to the same Jimmy Buffett album
every day for an entire summer and and
she when Jimmy Buffett comes on in
restaurants as often does happen she
gets up and she goes away if people sing
Jimmy Buffett songs in karaoke first she
spends about she spends about 13 seconds
staring directly into their soul and
making them make like like casting a
spell upon them and then she and then
she walks out of the karaoke bar to
stand outside until it's oh well now I
know to sink next time I do karaoke with
Catherine oh my god don't even say those
words she won't listen to the podcast
anymore
Nick bleep it out the Nick I'm serious
bleep it bleep bleep it all what about
bleep it bleep it I once I once had a
great conversation with somebody who
worked in the airport the Indianapolis
Airport has a like Hoosier specialty
shop that sells like Indiana related
gear mm-hm and in that Hoosier specialty
shop two movies play on a loop the movie
Rudy which is about a football player at
Notre Dame University which is here in
Indiana and the movie Hoosiers which is
about an Indiana basketball team and I
asked them you know like does that play
every day and they looked at me and they
just delivered the next four lines of
dialogue in the movie that's great and
so initially I was like what you just
said made no sense and then I heard the
characters in the movie saying that like
off to my left and I was like oh my god
so anyways Sam we're sorry maybe it will
help to think of the fact that it's not
Jimmy Buffett and it's not Hoosiers and
Rudy on repeat maybe that's the only
help we can give I I mean so what I
would say Sam is is if and when you're
ready to leave this job or maybe even
before then maybe if you are at the
point where you're saying I will leave
this job if this doesn't change if that
if that point ever comes I would go to
your direct supervisor and I would say I
think that it would help employee
retention and I think that it would make
our
I think it would make Nickelodeon
Universe more successful if we
diversified our soundtrack because
employees I hear them constantly
complaining about this they might not be
coming to you with it because they might
see it as potentially harming their jobs
but I think that it would I think it
would increase productivity and employee
retention which are two very important
things to all managers if we diversified
our playlists and I think they might
they might listen to you and you might
even get get a promotion out of the
thing
and if not then just move on and go to a
different show I would take that all the
way up the ladder forget about your
direct supervisor I would II I would
email the CEO of Nickelodeon and say
Nickelodeon Universe in the Mall of
America has a crisis that would be my
first sentence and my second sentence
would just be all the lyrics of boom
clap and then I would write in closing
and then I would write all the lyrics of
boom clap again and then I would write
sincerely Sam as a beautiful it's a
imeem it's not a terrible idea John and
to Sam I would just like to say to
finish this question off boom it goes on
and on and on an on damp boob clap you
make me feel good come on to me come on
to me now okay we're done all right I
hope Charlie XCX doesn't sue us for
copyright infringement Charlie I will
remind you that when I met you in Los
Angeles we had a nice conversation
please don't sue us all right that was
great I was beautiful question John this
one's from Russell who asks dear Hank
and John I find myself in a situation
I've never found myself in before I'm on
a long-distance bus journey overnight
and am in desperate need of a bathroom
break however there is a person next to
me and he is sleeping should I wake them
up and ask them to move climb past them
in the hopes for them and hope for climb
past them and hope for the best
or just suffer in silence your take on
this situation would be greatly
appreciated thank you and I'm sure you
appreciate the timely response that is
clearly not a problem for your current
journey that you I assume are still oh
yeah it took he asked this question nine
days ago so I am concerned about
Russell's health just from a like
waiting for the answer situation like
he's probably done
of a bladder explosion in the interim
nine days but which is a thing that can
happen oh of course you can die from
anything Hank literally anything can
completely end your experience of
consciousness at any moment but of more
concern immediately to Russell is the
fact that yet you just need to wake up
that person and crawl over them I like
to sit in the aisle so that I'm the
person who gets crawled over instead of
the crawler over because that always
feels less awkward to me but I don't
mind being woken up I understand that's
part of the deal like I signed on for
that when I signed on for this bus trip
yes absolutely that is that is that is
the case you could I mean if it's it if
it's a thing where you can try to get
out without waking them up that's fine
you can try to do that but if not just
hey I got to go to the bathroom they
don't want to be sitting next to a pile
of pee either so just do it that's a
great point Hank they don't want to be
sitting next to a pile of feet which is
what Russell presumably would have
turned into had his bladder exploded
yeah they don't want any nobody wants
that
clean fresh potty water or the or that
not clean fresh potty water come on can
we just let's move on this this used to
be a podcast about death now it's just a
podcast about potty humor our next
question comes from LeAnn who writes
Dear John and Hank my best friend is
getting married in October the closer
the wedding gets the more often I hear
questions like am I making a mistake
marrying him as her friend I value her
feelings and and want what's best for
her but I'm not quite sure what to say
my question is how can I help her decide
whether or not to marry him well you
know John I saw this question in the
podcast notes and I was like I'm not
touching that one with a 10-foot Pole
cuz I know not thinking about these
people's lives I I mean I also am not
very well acquainted with LeAnn or her
best friend or the person the other
person in this equation but I do have
advice I mean isn't this podcast
ultimately about giving advice based on
extremely limited amounts of information
advice that is in all likelihood not
helpful like isn't that literally our
business all right
you go go go go go for boy all right so
the thing about marriage is that it's
until you die
so I actually think that even if it's a
matter of like saying let's hit the
pause button here because I am suddenly
not sure that I want to get married I
think that's way better than hitting the
pause button like one hour into the
marriage like I'm a big fan of the the
pre marriage pause button but the best
piece of advice I can give Hank is go on
one of those stupid 2-day engaged
encounters I don't know if you did that
with Katherine before you guys got
married you have any kind of premarital
counseling or anything now we had seven
years of dating
well yeah but I I mean Sarah and I were
together for a long time - not seven
years but for quite a while and like I
was you know we were reasonably sure
that we wanted to marry each other
that's why we'd done the whole like
purchase of the engagement ring will you
marry me yes etc but I found this
two-day engaged encounter which I did
not want to do at all to be incredibly
helpful because I think really like when
I look back and Sarah and I've only been
married for ten years relative pittance
in the scheme of things but when I look
back at where we've been successful I
think most of the success that we've had
as a married couple has been because we
share each other's values it's not
really about it's not as much as I
thought it would be about romance or any
of that stuff it's mostly about like
sharing values so that would be where I
would start with the do I really want to
marry this person but I also would say
just don't be afraid to hit the pause
button here there's it's much better to
hit the pause button now than to try to
hit it when you've got like you know
four years of marriage under your belt
and you've got a legal contract to
dissolve a three yeah
or I'm wrong yeah that's very dubious
advice because I do not know these
people yeah I remember you telling me
some some things about that experience
where you were watching other people go
through the process and being like oh oh
some people really don't have it
together yeah I just remember this one
couple where they had a huge fight in
front of all of us because they had
never discussed whether they wanted to
have children I was like the first time
they had the conversation that's
something that you should yeah that's
something that you should discuss before
you go to your engaged owner
also lists on the Internet of like
questions you should talk about your
perspectives both with spouse with but
or before the matrimony occurs and if
you aren't comfortable talking about
those things with your prospective
spouse then that's not a good sign
yeah I mean there's all kinds of ways to
be married now don't pretend to be an
expert in it and lots of people have you
know great marriages I don't I don't
believe that like there's one right way
but I do believe that sharing values
mutual generosity those are really
important and have been like huge for us
in the last ten years agreed agreed
and also you know being able to talk
openly and honestly with one another I
think is pretty important if you're
gonna be on a team with anybody yeah and
your whole life together well I wasn't
gonna touch that I wasn't gonna touch
that cold refreshing potty water
question so I'm glad that we both got
one that the other didn't want to answer
okay well he's well here's another one
that's definitely for me from Joe who
asks dear Hank and John my name is Joe
and I'm sixteen years old not live in
the United Kingdom and I love coffee
when I woke up this morning I did the
usual ritual of making myself a cup of
coffee and while holding the copy off I
inhaled deeply to smell that wonderful
drink while doing this I thought of the
question could I get a caffeine buzz
just from inhaling the steam of my
coffee the particles that make up the
steam make their way into my lungs and
are diffused into my bloodstream also
I'm not sure if it's relevant to the
question but I drink my coffee black
with no sugar it's not relevant to the
question but thank you for letting us
know
you got any got any thoughts on that
John I assume that since you can vape
caffeine like using a vaporizing vapor
pen or whatever that you can that you
can inhale caffeine and I just don't
know if you do it when you drink in the
the water vapor from your coffee uh so
so there there are two different
mechanisms a vape pen actually create
like vaporizes the water but does not it
does not evaporate it it does not turn
it into steam and so the the they're
they're basically just really tiny water
droplets now I should say don't probably
do this because it's not well studied
but but the caffeine remains does
oh that's we're gonna get more letters
about that than we've ever gotten about
but the caffeine remains dissolved in
those water droplets and thus can get
into your lungs when it when it turns
into water vapor though the caffeine
does not remain in the water droplets
and that's what's happening when it's
leaving the top of your cup so you're
not actually smelling the water what
you're smelling is various volatile
organic compounds that are in the coffee
and there have been studies that have
shown that the smell of coffee those
different volatile organic compounds
that are going into your nose can
trigger the release of proteins that
might help shield you from the effects
of sleep deprivation at least that
happens in rats so the smell of that
liquid wakefulness might perk you up
psychologically and also physiologically
but it is not the caffeine that's doing
it which is really weird and interesting
to know that that coffee has more than
just the caffeine going for it and and
smelling it does you some good I
actually know someone who can't drink
coffee anymore because of health
problems but who brews a cup of coffee
every morning and smells oh I mean can't
you just smell the beams though wouldn't
that be cheaper I don't know I'm just
telling you what she does
oh all right that's fine don't judge
people for trying to get through this
vale of tears Hank we got another
question this comes from Austin who
writes Dear John and Hank I was just
thinking about how I along with a lot of
other people I think really enjoy sad
movies and sad songs and sad books in a
lot of cases particularly in music I
like them more than things that aren't
sad do you think this means I'd like to
be sad I don't think I like to be sad so
why do I like all this sad stuff well
John as you may be an expert in this as
a person who has created some media that
people intentionally read Ben
knowing that it's going to make them sad
but but I have recently recorded a
episode of crash course philosophy blog
about this and the and this sort of
philosophical problem of like why humans
go out of their way to make themselves
experience negative emotions whether
that be like a horror movie or a
tearjerker and and and there are a lot
of interesting thoughts on the subject
do you have any probably not as
interesting as like the thoughts of the
major philosopher
but I do have a couple the first thing
and Hank correct me if I'm wrong about
any of this stuff because this is all
just guessing based on my own experience
but the first thing is that I don't
quite think that sadness is the opposite
of happiness I think we've created a bit
of a false dichotomy
when we think of sadness as only a
negative emotion now sadness can be an
intensely negative emotion but sometimes
it's just sadness and sometimes I think
it's helpful to feel sadness in fact
like I used to be on a on a drug for my
OCD that caused me not to really be able
to feel sad like it was very difficult
for me to cry and stuff and I didn't
feel like I was my whole self I felt
like this part of me had been taken away
from me and even though it wasn't
necessarily a part of me that you know I
got I don't enjoy feeling sad but I
missed having that part of me and it was
an employee it felt like it was
important to me being me and it felt
like there was a real loss in not having
that but I will say I mean when I wrote
The Fault in Our Stars I thought that
you know it would be a book that would
be read by nerdfighters and people who
knew or liked my previous work by never
never crossed my mind that it would be
so popular just because it seemed to me
so sad like I mean I hope that it was
funny and fun to read and everything but
I knew that it was gonna be pretty sad
for a lot of readers and it didn't seem
like something that somebody would
choose to go through but I was totally
wrong yeah
the and philosophy I think that it may
be known as the problem of tragedy in
aesthetics and there's there's a lot of
schools of thought that there that this
is like and one of them is that this is
a way to maybe experience an emotion
that is very similar to but not quite
the real thing when you're experiencing
it and I think that that there's like a
spectrum of that but when you're
inspecting it in in media and in a play
or in a story and that but at the same
time like I also sometimes feel like it
is very much the real
thing when I'm experiencing it myself
but obviously you have a different
reaction to a scary movie than you have
to
something like that actually happening
to you directly and and so it's right
it's kind of like a way to get your mind
to go through the motions without
actually experiencing the truly negative
horrible thing and then there's there's
just the idea of catharsis which is just
it's like you get to like get it out of
you and do the thing and have the have
the emotion and and maybe that helps you
connect with or feel I'm just not the
right person to talk about this with
John I don't have I don't have no I
think that's an interesting idea though
III I think catharsis is an interesting
idea I also do think that there's
there's an element of a sad movie or a
sad book that allows you either to go
through the motions without having quite
the same negativity of of going through
it in real life or alternately that
allows you to kind of like glimpse back
to a time in your life when you did have
some tremendous loss or or some horrible
thing happen but it kind of like gives
you a lens of looking back at it that
that makes it possible to look at I mean
there's some things that are so
traumatic or so difficult that looking
at them directly it's just kind of too
painful that it becomes impossible to
look at them directly and so maybe it's
a it's it's a kind of lens backwards
that that gives you the ability to
actually look at it and think about it
and hopefully process it a little but I
don't know neither of us know is the
short answer Austin correct and I think
that it's a question people have been
talking about for thousands of years and
we'll continue talking about it so
you've tapped into something that is a
sort of fundamental weirdness of the
human condition we got another question
from Aquila this is a hard one John are
you ready for a hard one oh my god there
haven't been any easy ones today except
for the one about potty water
this is Aquila asks dear Hank and John
my mother recently got diagnosed with
type 2 diabetes and even though I know
that diabetes runs in our family I find
myself blaming her actions for getting
the disease this
because I feel it's the most effective
way of getting her to lead a healthier
lifestyle she's rather resistant to
change I felt that I've been acting with
her best interests in mind but Hank your
video has made me seriously question my
attitude what do you think is the best
way of getting her to be healthier
without making her feel guilty no I I
don't know if anybody saw my video about
this but I made a video on vlogbrothers
recently about how in particular with
the disease that one already has and
cannot do much about it can sometimes be
kind of destructive to tell people the
simple ways that you might think that
they might be able to heal themselves
whether that's going gluten free or VA
eating a vegan lifestyle or weird other
dietary practices that might not
necessarily work for them but does kind
of make the person feel as if you are
saying that they could if only they
could enact this simple thing in their
lives get rid of their disease and thus
you kind of feel like maybe their
diseases their fault and maybe that
makes them feel like their disease is
their fault that is indeed what your
video was about you wanna keep going
John oh no no no I was gonna let I was
gonna let you take on the question it
seems difficult okay first I think you
should remember that that while like I
like this is a thing that I hear a lot
people you know we talk about how like
the different causes of diseases and
sometimes forget that the number one
cause is just random chance
so while lifestyle contributes to
diseases lots of people are unhealthy
their whole lives and never get type two
diabetes they like we're all just
rolling the dice and while we can work
to improve our odds blaming someone for
their disease especially once they
already have that disease even if you're
just blaming them in your own head and
not out loud is basically wrong and it's
definitely destructive to your
relationship so it's not a thing that
you should do but we want the people we
love to be in the best possible health
and it can be really frustrating to
watch people go against the suggestions
of their doctors but change is super
hard and like like knowing that your
body is betraying you and that now you
have to live your life in a way you
don't want to live it because of this
betrayal it sucks and it might be really
like mentally challenging
and caused a lot of strife in the in
your loved ones lives so I feel like
empathy tends to be the best support
strategy understanding why it's
difficult and that it's difficult and
hopefully through your appreciation and
support of this person making it making
it easier for them to make healthy
choices and knowing that and helping
them know that this isn't a burden on
you but it's a fulfilling act that you
are helping out this person who you love
because because helping someone you love
is a wonderful pleasant thing to do yeah
I think the main thing is empathy I mean
it's incredibly hard for people to make
sudden massive lifestyle changes there's
lots and lots of research on how hard it
is how rare it is and it's important to
understand that that even when somebody
wants to make a change that you know
their doctors have asked them to make
it's incredibly difficult to do it
practically and you know sometimes
sometimes it isn't difficult but for a
lot of people it's very very hard and so
I think unless you're being empathetic
it I don't think you're increasing your
chances of like success in getting
somebody to make systemic change
I don't think shame works I don't think
yelling at people works and in many
cases I don't I don't think it's like
you said Hank I think that it's you know
it's it's pretty destructive in the end
I actually have a little bit of a
personal experience with this although
it's it's very different which is that
as you know Hank I have this disease
called eosinophils esophagitis which is
like an immune autoimmune disorder of my
esophagus that causes my esophagus to be
a little bit strictured and sometimes
food gets caught in my esophagus and
it's very bad when that happens because
if I can't get it up or down I can't
swallow my own like my own spit and so I
throw up like every two or three minutes
for hours and hours and hours until I
eventually get an endoscopy in the
hospital it's a real bummer and it's
it's a day ruiner you know like it
doesn't it's not ruining my life but
occasionally it ruins days and I went to
a really good specialist recently like
one
the best yo sena philic esophagitis
doctors in the country and he was
reading over my chart for a while
and he looked up at me and he said have
you thought about not eating steak
anymore and I was like what and he was
like have you thought about not eating
steak because it seems like 90% of the
times you've been hospitalized for this
it's been after you ate steak and I was
like huh you're right and he was like I
mean I'm not telling you how to live
your life man but I would cut out steak
but like that's a relatively easy change
for me to make you know like it's not
saying like okay you now need to stop
eating all processed foods and all
sugars right it's just saying that I
shouldn't eat this one thing and even
then I sometimes resent it but I will
say that since I stopped eating steak my
life has been way better it's funny
because I don't even like red meat I
have a very hard time understanding why
anyone prefers steak to chicken I mean
it's just clearly the best meat which is
why John this podcast is brought to you
by forbidden steaks for business tix.com
where you can acquire steaks but only if
you're not supposed to eat them today's
podcast is of course also brought to you
by boom clap boom clap the hit song off
the Fault in Our Stars soundtrack The
Fault in Our Stars movie by the way
excellent and now available on Netflix
oh and you can hear in that movie a song
that will make Sam run away from the
room screaming this podcast is also
additionally of course brought to you by
death by bladder explosion death by
bladder explosion not preferable to
waking up the person next to you
and lastly this podcast is brought to
you by cold fresh potty water cold fresh
potty water available now at forbiden
stay calm two things two things you can
get at that website and I have full
confidence in our business oh man thank
we're such good business people it's
amazing Hank I want to answer a couple
more questions before we get to the news
from Mars at AFC Wimbledon this question
really struck something it struck at
something deep in me it came it came
from Daniel and he wrote Dear John and
Hank I'm sincerely
that's actually just to me that that may
be why I liked it so much Dear John I'm
sincerely thrilled for you and your
soccer team as you all experienced such
historic highs although I myself have no
more interest in sports ball than Hank
however your enthusiasm has finally
inspired me to ask for a clarification
on a term I hear you use in reference I
think to Lisle Taylor the montserrat Ian
Messi can you explain to a non soccer
fan what a Messi is Hank do you know the
answer today and the ssy because of
course he thinks it's the adjective
message yeah Messi is a human being who
is very good at soccer is my impression
that is correct so Leo Messi is an
Argentinian soccer player who plays for
the club Barcelona he is probably the
best player in the world right now you
can google him if you want
it's mes si that will help you find him
I would I would encourage you to watch a
youtube video called Lionel Messi never
dives which will not strictly speaking
true does show seven minutes of people
hacking away at his legs and him
refusing to go down because he loves
being with his beloved soccer ball so
much um he's an incredible player and so
often you'll hear people refer to soccer
players as the Welsh Messi or the
English Messi as a way of saying well
he's not the greatest but he's the
greatest from England and since Lyle
Taylor plays for the Montserrat national
team I think of him as the Montserrat
Ian Messi
alright thanks for clearing it all up
for us Jonna that's a bit of cultural
reference that we're all we're all lucky
to have I've got another question
it's from Chloe who asks dear Hank and
John I'm so excited for nerdcon
nerdfighteria as soon as it was
announced at VidCon I was watching the
livestream I went online and bought my
ticket immediately thank you for doing
that Chloe you're the best it's gonna be
my first con ever do you have any tips
for a first-time con attendee well Thank
You Chloe
first of all for giving us an
opportunity to talk about
nerdcon nerdfighteria that we would like
all we will be doing a live performance
a live dear Hank and John show it's
gonna be in Boston Massachusetts
February 25th to 26th there's gonna be
many good times to be had it's gonna be
a very weird fun time we're gonna have
Craig benzine of wheezywaiter there jon
cozart Aaron Carroll Michael Buckley
Sabrina Cruz Joe and Paul - George of
Harry and the Potters Lindsey doe Emily
graslie Andrew Huang Charlie McDonnell
Megan Tangis who else am I forgetting
lots of your favorite people parrot gun
nerdfighteria so it's in February in
Boston you can go to nerdcon
nerdfighteria dot-com to get tickets
they are going fast so we hope to see
you in Boston we're really excited about
it it's like you know when VidCon first
started out it was largely nerdfighters
not exclusively but this is really the
first conference that's gonna be all
centered around nerdfighteria
and the work that we do together so
we're really really excited about it and
thank you for getting tickets first time
conference goer Emily whoo is that her
name Chloe I believe right that's what I
said but do we have any advice for a
first-time con attendee wear comfortable
shoes yeah is my number one piece of
advice it's also a good idea to bring
some some calories some packed some
packed calorie sources like balance bars
Hanks a big believer in bringing like
granola bars yeah to conferences which i
think is reasonably good at yes I mean I
I'm the first day of VidCon this year I
ate nothing except for Clif bars it is
the entire day yes not a healthy
decision but it was it worked for me
yeah the only other piece of advice I
would give you is you know look at the
look at the programming in advance so
you have a sense of what you really want
to go to but don't get too married to
the programming that you don't let fun
things happen so you know there are
always going to be kind of you know
discoveries that you can't plan in
advance and I think you have to leave
room for that stuff both in your head
and in your schedule so that you can
have the most fun possible but I do
think it's a good idea to look at the
Pro
and get a sense of like well I
definitely want to be there I definitely
want to be there yeah it's definitely
oftentimes the most interesting and fun
things are the things that just kind of
pop up and and as a conference planner
those are those mean a lot to me when
it's like oh this really special thing
happened and it's only because I put all
these people together in the same place
not because I even like intended for
that to happen and or planned for that
to happen so I I love that stuff and
also I would say be open to other folks
and you know know that they're into the
same things as you probably and make
make connections and friends and I think
that's that's that's really the best
part of going to going to an event is
that the people that you meet as much as
I work very hard to make the content
great I recognize that that in the end
it's that people get together in the
same place and get to have experiences
together I don't know where any nearby
pokey stops or or rare Pokemon are so I
can't give you any tips on I can't
believe they got through this whole
podcast with at once talking about
Pokemon go I have heard your phone buzz
about 14 times which I presume is
because right before we started
recording you laid down some incense no
no indeed that is not why just been
getting text from Michael Gardner but
there are no good Pokemon at my house I
have to go downtown to have good Pokemon
hunting but yeah I'm level 12 John what
are you I'm level 7 but I I will remind
you that I am playing with the 6 year
old so that slows me down a little bit
yeah I do feel a little bit like like I
might be I might be peaking it I'm
really far away from getting a hundred
and fifty pokemon or 151 or however many
there are
I have like 40 and I just feel like
that's it that's a really large bridge
to gap but who knows maybe I will
continue just sort of busting that out
every once in a while because it is a
fun fun thing it is a pretty great app I
feel like playing it I have glimpsed the
future but I also feel like playing it I
have thought hmm you know I might not be
doing this in a week
Yeah right right glimpse in the future
but not not the near future right right
right
this is the
step on a long process probably Hank
would you like the news from AFC
Wimbledon hit me alright well it's it's
the offseason as you know Hank AFC
Wimbledon getting ready for League One
football it has just been announced that
nerdfighteria will again be sponsoring
the back of Wimbledon's shorts oh nice
and we will also so was that was that
did that the price go up was that a
steeper for a league to thier league one
thing point being we're gonna do
everything we can to make sure that AFC
Wimbledon is successful in league one I
will personally do everything I can and
I know that you feel the same way we're
also gonna have all new advertising
hoardings along the along the stands in
the Kings meadow Stadium which we're
really excited about and and those are
being designed now so you'll probably
get to vote on them or get to see some
of them soon and the other piece of news
from AFC Wimbledon Hank is that our
beloved striker Adebayo Aachen phenoix
the Beast the strongest man in
professional football and maybe in the
world who left AFC Wimbledon was
released by the club at the end of the
season he has signed for a new team the
Wycombe Wanderers in League Two he'll
still be in the fourth tier of English
football next season but I know that he
will do amazing things for Wycombe or
possibly Wycombe it's just like
Gillingham or Dillingham nobody knows
for sure they finished 13th last year in
League Two and are hoping for better
things this year and I hope it for them
they certainly they certainly have made
a great signing in the form of Aachen
phenoix he is a Wimbledon legend and I
wish him well in Wycombe or Wycombe or
Wycombe be nobody knows how to how to
say it for sure
well John as far as the news from Mars
goes in addition to there being some
advertisements designed for at the side
of some stands at a stadium somewhere in
England the design of NASA's science
packed Mars 2020 Rover has been
completed all of its instruments have
been selected and it's ready for final
approval fabrication and assembly
the rover which doesn't have an official
name yet is based off of the same plan
as curiosity but it will explore
different areas of the second most
habitable planet planet in the Solar
System with some new tools it will be
collecting samples of like rocks and
dust and dirt and stuff and I'll be
putting those into like tubes sample
tubes that will later ideally and in the
plan be retrieved and returned to Earth
on a separate mission it will also have
microphones on it allowing us for the
first time to hear what it sounds like
on the surface of Mars which will just
be wind oh not really
but that'll be nice I guess it's plans
to launch in 2020 and land in 2021
leaving seven years after its arrival
for humans to get their butts to Mars
which seems more and more like a
terrible terrible method I've made
speaking of which Hank I'm starting to
feel like we have not done a good enough
job first off we've gotten through a
whole podcast without me once once
promoting my most important social media
channel twitter.com slash Leon muss for
Earth that's Ellie oh and mu SS number
for Earth but I was just thinking it's
funny that you think that it wasn't a
good bet because I was just thinking
that we need to dramatically increase
the stakes of this bet because just
having it be the name of the podcast I
don't lose anything if we get humans to
Mars before 2028 like there's nothing at
stake for me or for my hard-working
compatriot Leon Maas so we were thinking
it would be great to like dramatically
increase the stakes well as long as it's
just your side of the stakes that's
increasing I'm totally down no no I
would like to increase your side of the
stakes as well so I would like to add a
monetary component to this bet in which
the winner will have to give the money
to the chip to a charity a license
tax-deductible charity of the winners
the losers will have to give an X amount
of money to a charity chosen by the
winner but I don't I don't I think that
that's a good I like I think I think the
way that it is right now
was pretty good John I think it's funny
and I don't and you haven't even heard
how much money I'm proposing no I heard
X I heard I heard that it was an accent
well I've been thinking about the amount
okay is it a bear in mind that you have
until 2028 to make this amount of money
Hank is that more than two dollars it's
a billion I think we should bet 1
billion dollars to the charity of the
winners choice uh and I will remind you
I will remind you that the Don's trust a
AFC Wimbledon's ownership structure is a
charity I am NOT surprised
and unfortunately NASA is not let's just
make it 10 bucks let's make it an even
10 dollars just ours is much more
achievable for me though I do like the
idea of working with the actual normal
Elon Musk knowing that I'm gonna be a
billion dollars out if we don't get our
butts there knowing that I have to like
because of the bet that I've made really
up my game in terms of actual capital
generation and start making some riskier
bets for my financial future oh man all
right so it's $10 but it's it's a it's
gonna be adjusted for inflation so by
2028 if the earth dumpster fire keeps
raging it'll probably be a million
dollars but by then we won't be using we
won't be using money at all we'll just
be back to doing the barter system most
trade will occur in the form of like a
number of chickens
it'll be like yeah I'll give you eight
chickens if you notarize this document
for me that's the future Hank oh that's
the world we're on the cusp of all the
people who kept their pennies we'll be
so happy because they'll be able to melt
them down into actual usable products Oh
a darkness isn't circling us all Hank
what did we learn today we learned that
in addition to the fact that the world
is the literal dumpster fire there is a
downtown built around a shoe so there's
good news too yeah
we also learned that the coffee smell
does not contain caffeine but it does
contain something that wakes you up
we learned that helium tires will not
help float your car up and lastly we
learned that there is a young man named
Sam living in America's Twin Cities of
Minneapolis and/or st. Paul who has
suffered through the song boom clap
which is a good song
four thousand times so if the CEO of
Nickelodeon is listening right now and I
know that he or she is a friend of the
pod let's consider diversifying the old
playlists shall we yes a little playlist
diversification and maybe a promotion
for Sam because this is a problem that
needs to be addressed and no one brought
it up until Sam was brave enough to grab
the year of the person who I have now
looked up is sign Lazar gommi the the
president of Nickelodeon and Viacom
media networks Oh
dyma thank you for listen I thank cyma
from the bottom of my heart longtime fan
of the pod but all of your supports been
fantastic yeah the dollar on patreon is
just it's going a long way and we are
not spending it unwisely all right Hank
thanks to everybody for listening Hank
thanks for podcasting with me thanks
everybody for your questions you can
write us questions our email address is
Hank and John at gmail.com you can also
follow us on Twitter where Hank is Hank
green and I am Leon must for Earth or
you can follow us on Hanks preferred
method of communication snapchat where
Hank is Hank gr e our podcast is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins our intern is
Claudia Morales rosianna halse rojas
helps us out with the questions thank
you again for listening
our theme music sorry is by gunnarolla
thank you again for listening and as we
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]